dans une précédente vidéo j'ai pu
pénétrer et vous montrer une des prisons
kurde en syrie où sont détenus les
djihadistes de l'état islamique
vous pouvez le voir toutes les pièces
sont bondés
quasiment pas de place pour se déplacer
il n'y a quasiment pas de lumière du
jour
et si aujourd'hui ces prisons sont des
bombes à retardement
c'est notamment à cause de l'invasion
turque en octobre 2019
la turquie qui a envahi des territoires
jusque là contrôlé par les kurdes les
forces kurdes ont prévu dès le début de
l'opération que l'invasion turque
pourrait se traduire par une résurgence
de l'état islamique
pourquoi parce qu'elle ne pouvait plus
concentré leurs efforts sur la lutte
contre les cellules dormantes de
l'organisation terroriste parce qu' elle
ne pourrait plus assurer la même manière
la sécurité des prisons et des camps où
sont détenus d'oublier le djihadiste de
l'été yannick richard attali well i gr
jean calas cauchemar de près à ce que la
machine nebulae je vais je veux
giampaolo caruso
dans cette vidéo je vais essayer de vous
expliquer pourquoi des centaines de
milliers de personnes ont dû fuir leurs
villes et leurs villages
sous la pression de l'armée turque et de
leur allié syrien
[Musique]
je suis pour brut au nord-est de la
syrie plus précisément dans le
gouvernorat d'hassaké derrière moi c'est
le camp de déplacés de watch au cannet
où se trouvent principalement des kurdes
et des arabes qui ont fui les zones de
combats envahie par l'armée turque était
ces milices
[Musique]
pourquoi
donc là dans 76 lille nouveaux arrivants
du camp de washaw cas ni en fait ils
attendent de pouvoir récupérer 80
là il ya une cinquantaine de personnes
principalement des enfants en bas âge et
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
ils sont vraiment remplacer les uns sur
les autres
c'est aussi une ville de savoir ça de
façon générale une distribution de
nourriture ils ordonnent principalement
des boîtes de conserve pas qu'ils
allument des feux pour pas qu'ils
cuisinent dans la tente parce que ça
pourrait être très dangereux et c'est
principalement des boîtes de conserves
de haricots avec de la viande mais aussi
des chips
ça va
les jeunes ça général aoun tout leur
talent aller au delà des années pour
bien comprendre la situation de ces
déplacés en fait il faut remonter
quelques années en arrière vous préviens
c'est pas simple il faut s'accrocher un
peu à partir de 2014
c'est une alliance entre les forces
kurdes syrienne et la coalition
internationale contre l'état islamique
emmenée par les états unis qui a permis
de chasser les djihadistes du nord-est
de la syrie de reprendre leur capital
oreca après la défaite finale de l'état
islamique
les forces kurdes attendait de leurs
alliés occidentaux notamment américains
qu'il se maintienne sur place et les
protègent contre leur nombre aux rivaux
et ennemis régionaux notamment la
turquie
sauf qu'après la chute de dèche le
président donald trump avait annoncé à
plusieurs reprises qu'ils souhaitaient
le retrait des troupes américaines en
syrie et début octobre 2019
juste avant le début de l'invasion
turque il a fait cette déclaration sur i
c'est après un coup de téléphone
entrouvert doan et rhume que l'assurance
était donné au président turc que les
forces américaines allaient quitter deux
postes de la frontière syro-turque ce
qui permettrait bien sûr aux forces du
rite est alors allée d'entrée sur le
territoire
il faut aussi préciser que le président
turc recep tayyip erdogan considère que
les forces kurdes en syrie sont des
terroristes parce qu'elles ont des liens
avec le pkk le parti des travailleurs du
kurdistan
une organisation politique et militaire
considérée comme terroriste par la
communauté internationale et qui a déjà
revendiqué des attentats en turquie
la c6 v6 comme hiver cette montée en
puissance du mouvement kurde en syrie
soit donc à la frontière de la turquie a
commencé à beaucoup enquêté ankara qui
dès lors a fondé toute sa politique
syrienne sur l'objectif d' affaiblir
voire même de détruire le mouvement
kurde en syrie
le président turc justifier alors cette
opération militaire par la création
d'une zone tampon de 5 km de large à la
frontière turco syrienne
l'objectif de cette zone tampon et est
double d'abord chassé les forces kurdes
syrienne est ensuite installé des
centaines de milliers de réfugiés
syriens actuellement en turquie
je cherche
[Musique]
des choses que j'ai le plus entendu ou
dans le camp c'est le mot trahison les
kurdes ont vraiment le sentiment d'avoir
été abandonné par la coalition d'avoir
été jeté en pâture à l'armée turque et à
ses milices qui ont massacré et tué
beaucoup de gens il ya des vidéos qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux
la raclée leur maison mère
[Applaudissements]
sur le terrain ça tout n'était pas
uniquement des littératures qui est
engagée mais aussi des miliciens syriens
qui sont issus de groupes armés
islamistes qui ont combattu le régime de
bachar al assad depuis le début de la
guerre civile sérieux ces miliciens la
réputation d'avoir commis de nombreuses
exactions des exécutions sommaires des
enlèvements des tortures et ce sont ces
miliciens qui ont pris le contrôle petit
à petit le village de shah sont les
populations locales et notamment les
populations clos et justement dans le
camp
j'ai rencontré amira et sa famille qui
ont été victimes de cette offensive
militaire
elle a cinq enfants dont le dernier à
seulement deux semaines et elle a été
témoin des exactions des milices pro
turc âgées et ses histoires de massacre
tous les déplacés que j'ai rencontré la
bam en ont parlé et c'est en partie ces
traumatismes qui explique le sentiment
d'abandon qu'on les kurdes aujourd'hui
à l'effort sont curieux syriennes et
leurs alliés ont perdu plus de dix mille
hommes et femmes dans les combats contre
l'état islamique le retrait des forces
américaines de la frontière syro turque
en octobre 2019 l'a donc était considéré
par les kurdes qui estiment avoir mené
la guerre contre l'état islamique pour
le compte de la coalition internationale
comme une trahison
jim johnson 3 angie baraillé chine
richesse des trois passes et nous voilà
et de serge byrne chandler darshan à
haute énergie et en eau coach d'un vieil
homme divers riche et td bank gmbh et
0,15
[Musique]
j'ai beau être à même de recherche
attendra baisse charest couceiro jours
c'est beaucoup
[Musique]